- I've got some friends here.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Okay.
- From 30 Rock.
- Oh!
- [Doorman] May I bring them in?
- Yes.
(upbeat guitar music)
(crowd whistles and cheers)
- Ahhh!
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
(clapping)
(Kelly and guests chatting)
- You are so Texan right now.
- I know!
- That queso!
- That queso -
- I love you guys.
You brought queso!
- Was so heavy that my,
I was like, hold up.
My biceps are shaking.
- No, she was shaking
- [Seth Meyers] Yeah
- out there.
- They're shaky.
- This is true Texas girl though,
- [Jenna Bush Hager] Well, you know what
- because this is a vat of queso.
I love it, I'm gonna try it.
- Jenna made it.
Jenna made it.
It's her own personal recipe.
- You made it?
- Okay.
- I don't wanna reveal
where you can find it,
but if you get Velveeta and
you turn it over on the back.
- Y'all know Velveeta and Rotel.
- And Rotel!
- [Jenna Bush Hager] Right?
- That's Texas.
- And this is a single serving in Texas?
- It is.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah,
Yes it is, yep.
(audience laughing)
- You could do it for a family
- [Kelly Clarkson] Uh huh.
of four, if your kids don't eat very much.
- It's very good.
- Well, what's great
is you just reheat it.
Keeping it in the -
- [Jenna Bush Hager] Micro
- I'm all about that, yeah.
- That's right.
- Me too.
Welcome!
- Welcome to 30 Rock
- Thank you.
(crowd applauding)
- It's gonna be so fun.
(audience cheers)
- I love it.
- We've been waiting for you.
You fit here like a puzzle piece.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Aw, thank you.
- We're gonna be looking
for you in the elevators
and everywhere.
- I know, and thank you
for being a part of the
opening, it was so cool.
- It was so fun.
It was really fun.